oui tanguy tanguy le retour c'est le
titre du dernier film d'étienne
chatiliez qui fait suite au premier
volet sorti en 2001 un film qui a donné
son nom à cette génération de jeunes
adultes pas forcément pressés de partir
de chez leurs parents un phénomène qui
existait déjà au début des années 80
silva vous n'avez pas encore 18 ans vous
avez péché vos parents et vous êtes
heureux d'y être à part non voilà on
n'avait pas de projet de départ n'ont
pas pour l'instant il ne voulant que
rien chez vous crise du logement
manque de moyens ou encore par envie il
ya plusieurs raisons pour rester chez
papa et maman
la génération tanguy prend peu à peu de
l'ampleur si 41,1 % des jeunes de 18 à
29 ans habitait encore chez leurs
parents 1973 leur nombre a augmenté pour
atteindre 46 3 % en 1996
pour quelles raisons le coût de la vie
notamment compté 2001 à 2005 de loyer
après tu peux d'essence pour la voiture
pour toutes les taxes si on sort un
petit peu acheter à manger pour m'en
sortir et voit dans les années 90 les
jeunes sont les principales victimes du
chômage en 1978 6 5 3 % des 18-29 ans
étaient au chômage en 1996 c'est 15,7
pour cent des jeunes qui étaient sans
emploi
pour lutter contre ce fléau martine
aubry alors ministre de l'emploi créé
des emplois jeunes en 1997
objectif sortir de l'exclusion quelques
350 mille jeunes de moins de 26 ans en
2001 le nombre de jeunes sans emploi
diminue pour atteindre 10 8 % et le
nombre de tanguy suit cette tendance
mais c'est une joie de courte durée
puisque le chômage remonte à 17,1 pour
cent en 2013
résultat certains jeunes sont même
obligés de revenir vivre chez leurs
parents
au revoir la génération tanguy place à
la génération boomerang
eric deglane à 26 ans il est intérimaire
et gagne 1200 euros par mois cela fait
deux ans et demi qu'il est revenu chez
ses parents et il n'est pas près d'en
partir
en 2017 si les jeunes français ont
quitté le nid familial à 24 en moyenne
les parents français ne sont pas les
plus à plaindre en europe les jeunes
maltais très tanguy dans l'âme ont le
plus de mal à partir de chez eux avec
une moyenne de 32 ans
[Musique]